hello everyone this is one of the
greatest games ever played in in a world
championship match this is a Gary
Kasparov versus Anatoly Karpov there a
third a world championship match the
game was played in 1990 and the first
half of the match was played in New York
and the second half was played in lyon
france and after the first part of the
match after the first 12 games it was 6
to 6 the result and each player had one
win and the rest the rest of the games
were drawn but when they moved the games
to Leon because part will really started
pressing and it's interesting
Karpov actually had a interesting
suggestion for Kasparov before the match
even started so this was considered
somewhat of a psychological trick on
Karpov sparks
he suggested that since their first two
World Championship matches were
extremely close
the first match Garry Kasparov won 12
and a half to 11 and a half so only
would a half a point point lead and
their second match was actually tied it
was 12 to 12
so Karpov had an idea that if they tie
the match this time that maybe they
should keep on playing so you know a
victor would emerge and to this idea
across power of only said that mr.
Karpov is the Challenger and he must win
the match saying that if you can't beat
me in a matter of 24 games you don't
deserve to be champion man so I am let's
see this beautiful game and it's it's a
pretty theoretical rule opus but to the
position that arises after a couple of
moves is well spectacular so let's see
Kasparov is white and the Karpov is
black we have efore by gallery he 592 f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 so the real
Lopes k-6 Karpov goes for the Morphy
defense Bishop today for Knight to f6
because part of castles Bishop to e7
rook to e1 we have b5 Bishop to b3 b6
see three castles we have h3 and this is
still all theoretical
Bishop to b7 d 4 rook to e8
Knight B to d2 bishop to f8 a4 we have
h6 bishop to c2 now he captures on d4
and Kasparov capture C captures on d4
and we have
before attacking that Bishop and c2
Soaker spiral retreats it to be one and
this is a very useful movers now this
Bishop totally Anala is this nice
presence and before we have c5 by Karpov
d5 gaining some space 937 and here
Karpov is preparing f5 with a later
repositioning of the knight to f6 or
maybe even to e5 it depends but Kasparov
gets a very nice idea how to how to go
about this he plays rook to a3 preparing
rook to e3 if Karpov pushes f5 and
that's exactly what happens Carter went
f5 and Kasparov played rook to e3
we have Knight to f6 by Karpov and now
Knights to h2 this move will come in
handy very soon you'll see
Karpov plays king - h8 getting his King
out of this well nasty diagonal if the
position opens up and also has ideas of
pushing g5 I would have be three big
characters on a4 we have big captures an
a4 and our c4 by Karpov so ok he created
a pest see point very nice
we have Bishop to b2 and now Kasparov
has two extremely strong bishops here
and b1 and b2 we have F captures on e4
Knight captures on e4 and Knight
captures on d5 and Kasparov sacrificed a
pawn here for this attack but as you'll
see it was a well worth it he plays rook
to g3 we have a rope to e6 and now
adding protection to this sixth rank and
the Kasparov now post this night out of
H - he plays Knight to g4 and Karpov
plays queen te8 and this is where it all
starts this is where Caspar really goes
all-out and what happens next is well as
as the other videos on YouTube suggest
simply mind-boggling
so Kasparov played Knight captures on h6
and here it took carpeau a while to
calculate as far as ideas and in the end
he declined the knight sacrifice but
let's see what happens because this is
extremely interesting if this night
would be captured for example if a rope
captured on h6 you will get Knight
captures on d6 and now here there are so
many ideas the queen is attacked the
so Queen to d7 now attacking the knight
and here a lot of ideas are possible for
example the sparrow would play Queen to
g4 and now let's see what our water
carves options here you can obviously
capture the night with the Queen or with
the rook so let's see what happens if
Queen captures night if Queen captures
night then simply Bishop captures on g7
with Czech Bishop captures on g7 and the
Queen captures and g7 and this is
checkmate immediately so let's see what
happens if this rook captures the knight
if rook captures night then we have a
very nice Queen to h5 check and now if
the King goes to g8 well then simply
Bishop to h7 leads to quick checkmate
but if for example rook to h6 trying to
defend and this is where casparo
explains it really well he just captures
Queen captures on h6 and he says it's
been the pawn is pinned because black
cannot capture the Queen of course since
it's this bishop is spinning this pawn
on g7 so again this is completely
winning by Kasparov and lastly there
there is another idea after Queen to g4
so the knight obviously cannot be
captured neither by the Queen or the
Rose so Karpov could get ideas of
playing Queen captures Queen on g4 but
if it is displayed then simply unites
the f7 which check this F this h7 square
is covered by the bishop so only move is
King to g8 we have King to g8 and now
Knight captures rook with a check so G
captures on h6 and now rook captures the
Queen the King has to go to f7 and now a
very nice maneuver
Bishop to g6 check King to g8 and now
Bishop f5 would check King has to go to
f7 again Bishop to e6 check King has to
go to e8 and now Bishop captures a
knight on d5 open opening up a
discovered attack from drew Connie won
and next move Cora will capture this
Bishop on b7 and this is completely
winning because part of is a piece up so
let's go back to this position after
Queen to g4 so obviously it doesn't
really matter what car plays here
the mere idea of capturing that night on
h6 was enough you know to decline it
so after Kasparov played night to h6
Karpov went c3 so pushing his past pawn
of course why capture this night and go
through all this trouble and okay
Kasparov says okay you notified one of
my pieces but I still have one two three
four five six pieces ready to attack
your king and his power plays he moves
this night from age six he plays Knight
to f5 and the Karpov captures the Bishop
C capture sambito and here is power
plays Queen to g4 and as you can see
this is very very very unpleasant for
black carp of tries Bishop to c8 now
adding one more defender to the game but
simply Queen to h4 here and well because
he has to defend this if if carpel would
play something like King to g8 then
simply Kasparov says that King to h2 is
completely winning this Knight is now
free to jump to g5 because this rook
cannot be captured with Czech and black
is really what out and move here so
after Queen to h4 he played a rook to h6
and okay Knight captures on h6g captures
on h6 and now again cuz part of plays
King to h2 so in a crazy position like
this the key move is king to h2 we have
Queen to e5 and now power plays Knight
to g5 threatening 92f 7:14 the king and
queen so we have Queen to f6 and now a
very nice idea rook to e8 adding one
more piece into the attack and well
there's really not a lot of things
black can do here he Karpov tries Bishop
to a5 trying to give up one rook for
counter play but here Kasparov ends and
and this is a world championship game
this is around 20 so they already played
19 rounds both players are very
exhausted but cuz part of manages up and
the energy for a game like this and well
you're free to try and find cuz powers
next move and the idea behind it you'll
feel free to pause the video and okay
those of you who found the idea I
congratulate you
and those of you who haven't here's what
Gary played he played Queen captures on
h6 and this is a this was a pretty
historic moment as when Karpov saw this
move he just asked Kasparov for his no
cheat because casparo wasn't writing
down moves for the for I don't know how
many couple of moves so Caspar handed
him has no cheat and Kasparov was
rewriting all of Kasparov moves his own
note sheet and when he wrote down Queen
captures on age six he simply should
Kasparov's hand and couple resigned the
game but let's see what happens if if
Karpov would accept this Queen sacrifice
if Queen captures on age six then nine
twelve seven check we have King to h7
and now Bishop captures on f5 and the
King has nowhere to go this rook covers
the entire G file nightcap night covers
h8 so Queen to g6 would have to be
played and here rook captures on g6 is
completely winning it doesn't matter
that the material is even and even it
doesn't even matter that cargo is ready
to grab another Queen here and b1 okay
the bishop is protecting v1 but there is
no way of stopping mate wherever
Kasparov moves this rook it's checkmate
and even if carpet would try and stop
this for example with Knight to e7
simply capturing the night wins the game
rook captures Knight Bishop captures
rook and rope to g3 is instant checkmate
the rock is covering the entire G file
night night covers h8 and h6 and this is
well the bishop delivers checkmate so
yeah definitely a beautiful game and it
didn't go beyond this point of point of
Queen captures on h6 and Karpov did
manage to win one more game I think it
was game 22 but Kasparov won this match
as well and well definitely definitely
an important win in this match and the
third match also ended twelve and a half
to 11 and a half so a lot of a lot of
people think that the spar was actually
a lot better than Karpov but their their
mutual score was always around there you
know I think the two of them played in
maybe a hundred and fifty something
games throughout their career and it was
only a couple of points in Kasparov
favor so definitely one of the greatest
rivalries in chess history so yeah
that's it I do hope you enjoyed this
beautiful game it's like I said game 20
of the world championship match third
championship match Kasparov vs. Karpov I
would like to thank the David Deutsch
and the Ricky Brown thank you for
contributions to my channel I really
appreciate it and as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and
that's it thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon